Other controllers include Ryu, which is
an open source Python controller. Ryu supports
OpenFlow 1.0, 1.2, and 1.3, as well as the Nicira extensions. It also works
with Open Stack. The support for the later versions of OpenFlow. And the
integration with the open stack, are advantages
over other SDN controllers. Because Ryu is
implemented in Python, it still does not
perform as well other SDN controllers, such
as nox. Another popular SDN controller is
floodlight. Floodlight is written in Java. It supports
Overflow 1.0, and is a fork from
the early beacon controller. Floodlight is maintained by
big switch networks. Advantages include good documentation,
integration with the rest API, and good performance.
Unfortunately it also has a fairly steep learning
curve. So you should use floodlight is you
already know Java, if you need production level
performance and support. And you will use the
rest api to interact with the controller. So
we can compare these two controllers, with the
two controllers that we already discussed, Nox and
Pox. We have controllers in three different languages,
Python, Java, and C++. We have controllers
that support later versions of open-flow, and
support open stack. And we have controllers
that provide better performance, as well as controllers
that are easier to use for rapid prototyping. All of these controllers are still
relatively hard to use, because they entail
interacting directly with open flow, flow table modifications.
Which operate at a very low level of
matching on flows and performing specific actions. As
we'll see, it's possible to develop programming languages
on top of these controllers, that make it much
easier for a neetwork opeartor to reason about
network behavior. Before we jump into higher level programming
languages however, let's first see how we can
use these existing control frameworks to customize network control.